previously on Mars we knew Mars wouldn't
welcome us with open arms warning system
offline permission is sweet from primary
to backup do it every bunch of abalzer
we were ready to give everything to get
there
Mission Control this is Daedalus we're
looking at a red planet we'd have to
fight even harder than we wanted to stay
how far did we overshoot seventy five
point three kilometers
Mission Control confirmed the rover's
2,000 killer's over maximum payload
that's hurt I won't make it but no
matter what happened we do everything we
could to make the workshop module our
new base camp
because the thing that kept us pushing
it wasn't just inside us our species has
always been driven to build beyond what
we know
we migrated across all of earth created
settlements constructed cities and when
we finally left our home planet
we knew the risks involved as we set
sail we ask God's blessing on the most
hazardous and dangerous and greatest
adventure on which man has ever embarked
however will is a double-edged sword
again and again it's taken us farther
than we ever thought we could go but
this time we had seized on an object so
vast so difficult to attain I couldn't
help but wonder if we might have finally
pushed too far